i rushed her to the emergency room it's
probably not safe i shouldn't be saying
any of this
ellen degeneres had the wildest 420
experience
except it actually wasn't 420 it was a
month earlier
you know it was the greatest thing on
tuesday's episode of jimmy kimmel live
the 63 year old talk show host noted
that she's never had success getting
high
then recounted a night she consumed
three drinks that contained
thc and cbd that had been gifted to her
by
chelsea handler they have cbd or
th i don't know what the good thing is
but it has something that's
supposedly this is another one like uh
no this is different
so i i i drank one and i didn't feel
anything and i drank so i drank three
and then i took two like melatonin sleep
pills
ellen added that her wife portia de
rossi had hit the sack
early that night saying she wasn't
feeling well
and i'm laying in bed and i realized
she's not in bed
and i hear i said are you okay and she's
like uh
and i said baby are you okay and and i
she's moaning i get out
of a bed and she's on the ground on all
fours
so um i rushed her to the emergency room
and
uh they heard you drove her yourself i
did i mean i
kicked in like my adrenaline was like
because i just had to rush her there so
it's probably not safe i shouldn't be
saying any of this
[Laughter]
but it's a good thing ellen got porsha
to the hospital
because she ended up having an emergency
surgery to remove her appendix
i mean there's some cray-cray stuff
happening and while ellen says
porsha is much better now she joked that
her wife was in so much pain at the time
she was using the ellen degeneres show
as a bargaining chip
she uh was begging for more pain pills
because she was still in pain and the
nurse was like
not giving them to her so she starts
offering up
tickets to my show she starts to dinner
but yeah like
she's like bargaining like upping it to
12 days like what about the christmas
12-day show like
last month ellen addressed porsha's
emergency surgery on her daytime talk
show
uh anybody else have to rush their wife
to the emergency room for an
appendectomy
anybody no just me okay
and prior to porsha's health scare ellen
had one of her own in december when she
revealed she was battling covet 19.
she posted this statement to her
instagram assuring fans that she was
feeling fine
and following proper cdc guidelines
we're glad both ellen and porsha are
doing
much better now
you